okay so i've got a bunch of clips to
play for you we're going to get them out
of the way in this segment then move on
to an interview we've got a lot of a lot
of other things but i i
your if i didn't cover this you'd really
be missing a lot of important
uh sort of narrative changes that are
taking place right now
from the white house and in the context
of the 2020 presidential election donald
trump
uh did both a press briefing and an
interview with fox news host laura
ingram
last night i'm going to start with the
interview with laura ingram which donald
trump was promoting
all day multiple times tweeting things
like for example i will be interviewed
on ingram angle tonight at 10 pm on fox
news
enjoy and there are a lot of really
interesting sort of psychological
dynamics going on right now in terms of
donald trump taking on these interviews
and winging rallies as he said in new
hampshire over the weekend and so on
because remember that donald trump
believes he always is the smartest
person in the room and that no matter
what people throw at him he's going to
come out
looking good and this is why donald
trump at least seemed open to the idea
of sitting down with robert mueller back
during the russia investigation days
something which his lawyers
knew would be a terrible idea that
donald trump would lie
he would perjure himself it would be a
disaster and they were able to keep him
from doing it
and so the context of trump coming in
thinking he's going to be super
effective
went bad really quickly yesterday in
this interview with laura ingram where
she regularly would try to sort of
interrupt and redirect
trump because she realized that he was
going in a completely wacky
direction there are probably more than
just these instances i'm going to play
for you and we'll look at some of these
in more detail
but look at all of these moments where
laura ingram just
interrupting trump to try to divert or
redirect
what are disastrous paths for him to be
taking essentially trying to
save donald trump from himself they say
that when you walk through
the streets of portland
this is years and years of burning and
it's in the last 90 days it's been
really no no it's been
horrible in the last night but no it's
people that are in the dark shadows
people that what does that mean that
sounds like conspiracy theory
dark shadows people that you haven't
heard of they're they're people that are
on income housing and with that comes a
lot of other problems including crime
may not be nice to say
people are criminals though no i'm not
saying that at all but it does there is
a
level of violence in the meantime he
might have been going for a weapon and
you know there's a whole big thing there
but they choke just like
in a golf tournament they miss a three
foot they're not comparing it to golf
because of course that's what the media
i'm saying people choke people with my
people joke
and now i do wonder you know we'll never
know
but does someone go to laura ingram and
say listen
if trump starts going down this path or
that path
try to interrupt it try to get in the
way or is she doing that out of her own
desire to help donald trump we don't
know now
let's look at some of the details of
what was discussed we talked yesterday
about donald trump bringing in this guy
a neuroradiologist a doctor but not
someone who has anything to
you know any expertise in infectious
disease scott atlas who is pushing
for a herd immunity approach to dealing
with the virus i told you yesterday why
it would be a disaster
here is donald trump now i told you it
would happen donald trump's starting to
push this idea
mission of americans frankly in both
parties who
aren't comfortable well once you get to
a certain number
you know we use the word heard right
once you get to a certain number
it's going to go away so you know it
doesn't have to be
but yeah i mean a lot of people are not
going to want to do it a lot of people
don't want to
do the flu should it be mandatory you
know i never had the flu but i never had
a shot i never had the vaccine
i come here the first thing sir you have
to have a flu shot
i said why because you have to have it i
say what's the percentage and i wasn't
thrilled with the percentage you know
it's like fifty percent
fifty-five but dr fauci said it might
not give quote great protection
because it's a coronavirus well i said
look if i've never had it wouldn't it be
good
and then i thought i should have it
because i'll set an example so i had it
so i've had it now
three times but and i still haven't had
the flu
so maybe i'll give credit to the flu
vaccine i don't know so
of course donald trump seems still to be
confused about flu vaccines we're going
to skip that just because i can't cover
everything
but i did the math for you on herd
immunity yesterday so
here are the numbers for the level of of
contagion
for how easily spread coronavirus is to
get to herd immunity you need 50 to 83
percent of the population to be immune
if you pick a number in the middle it's
67 it's like two-thirds
now with a one percent death rate and
331 people
331 million people in the country if you
do some back of the envelope math if
two-thirds of the country gets the virus
that's about 220 million if one percent
die
it's about 2.2 million deaths meaning we
still have 2 million deaths to go to get
to herd immunity
if you think the death rate is more like
0.75
then you're still looking at about 1.5
million dead
from where we are today so the herd
immunity idea
is downright dangerous and donald trump
understanding nothing is pushing it okay
let's continue
donald trump suggests listen if you
don't count the state of new york
in coronavirus numbers we're doing way
better
bad decisions on nursing homes he's the
number one state in the country by far
for death i mean probably in the whole
world
for death you take new york out of the
equation i think we have among the best
numbers anyway but you take new york we
have the best numbers in the world
countrywide
no andrew uh so this this is one of
those meaningless
claims right if you take out the top
five states
our numbers are way better if you don't
include nursing homes
we reduce the death toll by like 40
percent if you take out people over age
75 this virus really hasn't been that
much of a disaster
this is imaginary nonsense does trump
know that it's nonsense
i don't know i actually don't know here
is donald trump
sort of weirdly second guessing police
incidents
and we saw a little bit of a preview of
this earlier in the compilation of laura
ingraham
trying to help trump hear trump likens
police incidents to putting in golf
where sometimes
people choke you know a joker they choke
shooting the guy shooting the guy in the
back many times i mean
couldn't you have done something
different couldn't you have wrestled
you know i mean in the meantime he might
have been going for a weapon and
you know is a whole big thing there but
they joke just like
in a golf tournament they miss a three
foot they're not comparing it to golf
because of course that's what the media
i'm saying people choke people people
choke
and uh an outrageous analogy of course
and laura ingram realizing it and trying
to do
instant damage control for donald trump
but it just kept getting worse and worse
this next clip is a really interesting
insight
into the psyche really of donald trump
take a look at this
feel like me they feel like every time i
put law and order up
on social media it gets such an
incredibly
positive response the people of this
country will not stand for it
so trump recognizes whenever he
posts a tweet law and order in
all caps a lot of people like it
it gets a good response notice that he's
saying
i get a good response not when i do
anything
but when i post law and order this is a
microcosm of the entire presidency
during the chris wallace interview in
july
this is by the way i tweeted about this
this is relevant to bring up trump said
during the chris wallace interview in
july
within two weeks we will have a signed
and delivered new health care law
it's going to replace obamacare it's
going to be done in two weeks that was
in july
that came and went during august trump
was asked about it he said
we're going to do it at the end of the
month and trump is start saying trump's
doing new health care trump's doing
health care
as you probably know it's now september
august 31st came and went and trump
didn't do it
trump either recognizes or simply
doesn't care
that he doesn't actually need to do
stuff
he gets a lot of the political benefit
just from saying he's going to do it and
that's exactly what he's saying here
when he says
i post law and order and people
absolutely love it
then trump went into wild conspiracies
about the city of portland for example
which he claims has been burning for
years
they say that when you walk through the
streets of
portland this is years and years of
burning and
it's in the last 90 days it's been
really no no it's been
horrible in the last night but no it's
been going on for many it's been going
on for
many many years it's like you're in
i won't name the city but it's a city
someplace in the world that's not so
good okay
it's a terrible city the oregon governor
said portland has been
burning from years like what is that
what does that even mean
firefighters just let things burn for
years
import none of this makes sense the
facts don't matter
but this is the narrative trump has
chosen trump has staked out
this place in order to get himself from
now until election
the election he's made the calculation
it may work it may not
that chaos is good for him even though
the chaos is happening under his watch
it may work and it may not and i got
some interesting pushback yesterday from
people writing and saying david
here's why your take is wrong the chaos
won't work for donald trump
and we'll discuss that but the point is
trump thinks it will help him
he was asked would he put dr fauci in
charge
again if he were to do it all over again
you had to do it all again i know that's
kind of a hard question but do it all
again would you put fouchy
front and center every day in charge of
the coronavirus task force i get along
with him very well i disagree with a lot
of what he said he said keep it
open for china that was a big mistake
and he admits it
uh i just i get along with him but every
once in a while he'll come up with one
that i say
where did that come from i inherited him
he was here he was a part of this huge
piece of machine i didn't put anybody in
charge he was here
he was he's been here for forty years
eighty four
nineteen eighteen okay he's been here
for many many years uh
but and i you know you inherit a lot of
people it's part of the machinery
he inherited fouchy he says sort of like
a stepchild that came with your partner
came with a relationship i inherited him
so no real answer
there and then again restating this
wild claim that he's done more for black
people than anyone except maybe abraham
lincoln but maybe even more than abraham
lincoln do anything for them
i've done more and i said in the speech
some people said you shouldn't say it
it's too aggressive i said what's
aggressive
i've done more than any president in the
united in the history of our country
except for maybe abe and i say maybe
maybe abraham lincoln the reason i say
maybe is i'll explain that to you later
okay
all right the funny that every time
trump says this
nobody says what about lbj maybe
jonathan swann from axio said what about
lbj although i don't i don't remember
and if he said it i don't know that
trump even heard it
i'm going from memory but aside from the
lincoln conversation nobody mentions lbj
in this discussion it i can't even
pretend that this is serious but trump
continues to say it
and then here is where it gets really
just dystopian
in explaining that someone is secretly
controlling
joe biden right now donald trump
suggests
that there was some kind of thwarted
terror plot
against the republican convention
involving
thugs on a plane but he won't go into
detail
he's not controlling anything who do you
think is pulling biden's strings
is it former obama people that you've
never heard of
people that are in the dark shadows
people that
what does that mean that sounds like
conspiracy theory dark shadows people
that you haven't heard of
they're people that are on the streets
they're people that are controlling the
streets
we had somebody get on a plane from a
certain city this weekend
and in the plane it was almost
completely loaded with
with thugs wearing these dark uniforms
black uniforms with gear and this and
that they're
they're on a plane where's the words
i'll tell you sometime but
it's under investigation right now but
they came from a
certain city and this person was coming
to the republican national convention
and there were like seven people on the
plane like this person
and then a lot of people are on the
plane to do big damage
so is that completely made up
probably not it's probably not
completely made up it's probably a
combination
of something that happened which trump
first
misunderstood and then exaggerated
that's as i apologize for hitting my
microphone there it's probably
something trump misheard and is
exaggerating now
for some unclear and unknown benefits so
this is the president
talking about you know a plane loaded
with
thugs and black uniforms i wonder if
their uniforms were the only things
that were black about those so-called
thugs that's certainly a question
and then he says he says this person but
was it a person or was it a group
even laura ingram unable to save donald
trump and remember
donald trump's psyche allows him no
consideration other than
i'm going to crush this interview i'm so
smart i'm so good at being interviewed
that everybody's gonna come away super
impressed unfortunately
i think some of his followers do come
away from an interview like this super
impressed
the reality is absolutely horrifying
almost as horrifying as donald trump's
press briefing which i want to talk
about next
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video